in this video I want to continue that
our talk of the pentose phosphate
pathway and talk a little bit more about
the non oxidative phase because in the
previous video we kind of focused a
little bit more on the oxidative phase
we said in the last video that the
pentose phosphate pathway produced two
things those two things were NADPH and
rib you Lowe's five phosphate and we
said that the NADPH provided reducing
power for biosynthesis for anabolic
pathways and then ribulose 5-phosphate
was used as a precursor to different
nucleic acid synthesis now Regulus 5
phosphate I've drawn it here it's in the
last video I referred to it as our 5p in
this video and henceforth I will refer
to as our u5p
and the reason why is because rib ulos 5
phosphate can be turned into this other
molecule here called ribose 5-phosphate
and that's something we mentioned in the
previous video kind or at least we
hinted at it we said that ribulose
sounds a lot like ribose so rib ulos can
be turned into ribose 5-phosphate and
now ribose 5-phosphate something i will
actually refer to as our 5 p hands for
the enzyme that catalyzes this reaction
is called phospho pentose isomerase
phospho pentose isomerase and then they
make sense both of these compounds are
pentoses there are five carbon sugars
that have phosphate groups so phospho
pentose make sense and isomerase makes
sense because they're only slightly
different rib EULA's 5 phosphate is a
ketose right it has this carbonyl here
in between two carbons
whereas ribose 5-phosphate and aldose it
has it's a carbonyl up here as an
aldehyde okay now that's ribose
5-phosphate of course a precursor to
many biomolecules including some nucleic
acids okay so now further things we
should already know from the previous
video is that pentose phosphate pathway
the pentose phosphate pathway diverts
off of glycolysis at g6p glucose
6-phosphate
so once glucose 6-phosphate is created
it can either continue in glycolysis or
go to the pentose
so a pathway another thing that we
should already know is that the
oxidative phase of the pentose phosphate
pathway makes NADPH and rebel OHS five
phosphate which of course can be turned
into ribose 5-phosphate from that
reaction we've just seen there okay
now you talk about the yuan oxidative
phase I'll talk about more details in
just a second but we should be familiar
at least to a certain extent with these
terms here so I'm going to be referring
to things mostly by these abbreviations
here these are all a bunch of
monosaccharides so our u v p and our v p
regulus 5 phosphate and ribose
5-phosphate are both 5 carbon molecules
that we've already encountered but the
rest of these things here X 5 p xylose 5
phosphate g3p cholesterol the high 3
phosphate s7p it said you said oh heck
do low 7 phosphate efore p re throws
four phosphate and f6p for just six
phosphate I'm not actually going to be
drawing all these different things so
I'm just going to be referring to them
by their abbreviations but what's most
important is that you recognize how many
carbons each one of these molecules is
and that will help you understand the
pathway so X 5 P is a far cover molecule
and actually any that the numbers here
actually refer to how many carbons there
there are no they don't refer to it the
the number indicates where the phosphate
is but those the phosphates are all in
the ends of these carbon chains
so let's write a 3 phosphate is a three
carbon molecule Sedo hep Tilos seven
carbons
it reads those four phosphate four
carbons for just six phosphate six
carbons we've actually seen with
draw-tite three phosphate for physics
faucet before in glycolysis okay let's
move on to the actual non oxidative
phase well if you recall we talked about
it or we mentioned it in the previous
video as being just a series of carbon
shuffling reactions who are moving
carbons around so what is the overall
process though in the overall process
we're taking 3 rib ulos 5 phosphates and
turning them into 2 F 6 PS and 1 g3p
let's see if that makes sense
if we have 3
five carbon molecules here that's a
total of 15 carbons that we're starting
off with how many carbons do we have
over here
well f6p we said was a six carbon
molecule g3p with a three carbon
molecule so the total number of carbons
that we have here is 12 carbons and here
three carbons for a total of course of
15 carbons we go from 15 carbons to 15
carbon so everything's cool there so
something that you should bear in mind
about this process for starting off with
three really lows 5 phosphates and
turning them into 2 2 F 6 p.m. 1 g3p
it's important to recognize that all of
these reactions are reversible okay
that's very very important I'll get to
get to why later so let's say we start
off with 3 review lows 5 phosphates ok
like we set up here in the overall
process so we said that are you 5 P can
be turned into R 5 P right another 5
carbon molecule you can also be turned
into X 5 P so is iolo's 5 phosphate now
if we have three regulars five
phosphates and we're going to turn them
into our five P and X 5 p we're gonna
have to of 1/2 of one of these and one
of the other we're actually going to
make one rivulet 5 phosphate or ribose
5-phosphate excuse me r phi p + 2 x 5 PS
this top reaction here we just mentioned
earlier is that fossil pentose isomerase
catalyzes that reaction to go from ru 5
p 2 x 5 be the different enzyme called
phospho peanuts at burma race and
epimers are actually just diastereomers
that differ in chirality at only one
chiral Center I encourage you to go back
and look through the structures of all
these different compounds but I did not
draw them in this video just for
simplicity sake and before we can
actually talk about the steps in the
reactions of the non oxidative phase we
have to understand this simple detail
here there are enzymes called trends
keto laces and there are enzymes called
trends alder laces the trans keto laces
catalyze reactions that transfer to
carbons and trans out laces
for three carbons in the reactions okay
so let's get into the actual steps for
the reactions of this pathway first
steps we're going to take 1 X 5 P and 1
r 5 P which are each both 5 carbon
molecules and we're going to turn them
into one g3p and 1's 7 p ok which is one
three carbon molecule one seven carbon
molecule now specifically we're going to
take this 1 X 5 P and turn it into this
g3p so we're going from a 5 carbon
molecule to a three carbon molecule and
then we're going to take this R 5 P and
turn it into this s 7p so what happened
basically while actually let's think
about this which enzyme catalyzes step a
trans aldolase or a trans catalase well
if we went from x5p to g3p that means we
lost two carbons there right
well what happened to those two carbons
our 5p went from 5 carbons to 7 carbon
so it must have gained those two carbons
so we had a two carbon transfer here
that means we had a two carbon donor and
a two carbon acceptor the donor is on
the the x5b because it lost those two
carbons and our 5p is the acceptor
because it gained those two carbons this
it was a two carbon transfer that means
we had a trans key to lace catalyzing
this reaction cool that's pretty much it
until the first step so how many are you
5p equivalents have we used so far well
we have 1x 5 p.m. when our 5p so that's
two of them both of those are five
carbon equivalents that came from our
u5p
so we had 1 X 5 p + 1 R 5p used in the
second step we're going to take this g3p
n s7v that we made and we're going to
turn them into f 6p + e 4p specifically
this g3p will be turned into f 6p
and this s7p will be turned into e4p
so how many carbons were transferred
well if we went from a three cover
molecule to a six carbon molecule things
we gained three carbons there and then
those three carbons must have been lost
by the s7p
so we had a three carbon transfer so we
have a three carbon donor and a 3 carbon
acceptor the 3 carbon acceptor is the
g3p because it gained 3 carbons to
become an f6p so we have the acceptor
was g3ps 7p was the donor because it
lost those 3 carbons so s7p here and if
this was a 3 carbon transfer then it
must have been a trans
aldolase that catalyze this reaction
that's it for the second reaction or the
second step so so far how many are you
5p equivalents that we use well still
just to write we we had the 1 x5p and
the 1 are 5p that we used up in the
first step and those things were turned
into the g3p n s 7p so we haven't used
that third equivalent yet in this third
step third reaction we're taking an x5 P
and an e 4p that we just created so we
just took this e 4p here that we just
created and we're adding an x5 p so this
x5 p is going to be turned into this g3p
so here we're going from here to here
and then this e 4p will be turned into
this f6p
so this thing gained two carbons right
going from 4 to 6
and this thing lost two carbons so we
had a two-carbon transfer that means we
had a two carbon donor and acceptor the
donor was x5p because it lost the
carbons eforp II gained 'm so it was the
acceptor and this of course then because
the two carbon transfer was catalyzed by
a trans catalase at this point how many
are you five PT equivalents have we used
so far well now we've used all three
right we had the initial one had that
one X Y P and the one our 5p from the
first step and now we just use this 1 X
5 feet here so we've used all of them ok
so now we said before that the overall
reaction was going to take 3 ru 5 PS and
turn them into 2 F 6 PS and 1 2 3 P how
did that actually happen well we should
be able to go back and look at these
three steps and think to ourselves okay
what did we create and what did we use
up ok so here in that first step at the
top we took an x5 p and turn it into a
g3 5 P and R 5 p turn it into a g3 P and
s 7p those that one g3 P and s 7p were
both used up so we can go ahead and
cross this here anything that's a little
both the left and right side right here
we cross that off it's created and then
it's used up created and used up so
those shouldn't be in the overall
reaction and same thing with this e 4p
here had it we created it and then we
used it up so what do we have left over
okay on the left side of the reaction we
have 1 X 5 P 1 are 5 feet here that's 2
R u 5p equivalence and here's the third
one here so on the left side we have the
3r u 5 piece and on the right side
nothing there we have 1 FF 6 P here 1 f
6p here and 1 g3p here so that is
to f6 PS and one g3ps so we're basically
took three review lows five phosphates
and turn them into two F 60s and one g3p
what we notice about these two compounds
they are actually glycolytic
intermediates so they're from glycolysis
so if we have a lot of our u5p and they
have if there's if it's an excess that
means we'll create a lot of f6p and and
g3p and those things can go to
glycolysis so if there's an excess
glycolysis can happen okay but this is
kind of weird wait a minute I thought we
said in the previous video that the non
oxidative phase makes our 5p when NADPH
is not needed what happened why did we
create f6p and g3p that doesn't make any
sense
remember the reactions are reversible
that's what's important here so
basically if we have f6p and g3p we can
go backwards and create a bunch of
r u5 p and r ER 5p and we can make a
bunch of this okay so we can go the
other way okay so we go backwards and
make our five feet without making NADPH
because if you go back and look at all
the steps that we just talked about none
of them mentioned in ADP H so there's no
NADPH or nadp+ at all so if we run this
reaction backwards we can create our 5p
without making NADPH hope that video was
helpful thank you for watching
hey folks my name is mo food I am a
tutor I graduated from UC Riverside with
a degree in biology and on graduation to
add a little bit of trouble with the
wind that's you can tell the subject
that suited for are listed here in the
description below you'll find my email
address if you have any questions and
you'll also find the links to two
listings my university tutor listing
which is for in-person tutoring and my
Google helpouts listing which is for
online tutoring thanks for watching